[Musique]
ouh ouh
sur sept gagnants vamara ciani
[Musique]
en 2012 je l'apprécié l'apprenti créé à
la voile certaines personnes et à 5 y
mon père ma mère et ma tante 90
paraîtrait que j'ai adoré et si le vent
que je tombe en amour un peu avec
l'océan atlantique
je travaille maintenant depuis un peu
plus de 200 sur un projet de ramos
yannick que voit traverser l'atlantique
nord un équipage de deux cet été
[Musique]
mais vous trouvez bryan qui lui est de
l'irlande mais qui avait déjà traversé
le pacifique à la rame
il est embarqué dans le projet et on est
parti ensemble contraire c'est la fin
alors à traverser initial devait prendre
environ entre 60 et 70 jours on l'a fait
en 38 jo donc vraiment été super content
and la vitesse à laquelle on a traversé
5 est un groupe d'affaires publiques
autant de ramener de 12 à 14 heures par
jour et tous tes blessures qu'on peut
avoir la foi c'est un gros gros défi
pendant deux semaines sur les qui
complètement gelé
[Musique]
la force physique s'expose plus haute
distinction de leur force mentale et la
force mentale c'est ce qui permet de
passer par dessus les difficultés
physiques
le choix est réglé ce qu'on peut avoir
le trois reprises son écran des gros
gros coup de vent ou les vagues étaient
beaucoup plus impressionnante
une fois la vague passé ce bateau on
avait de l'eau jusqu'aux épaules et on
essaie de faire porter
je 4 heures du matin justement il ya une
vague qui a fait chavirer le bateau est
comme lui un truc à anvers un peu plus
rien du tout en te rendant l'eau et on a
pu accéder au sauvetage des banques de
détresse avait été arrachée grave parce
qu'on n'est pas là mourir le nul aux
siens au bout de deux heures c'est vrai
qu'il ya différents c'est vraiment être
confus par le froid n'est pas terni
personne c'est vrai qu'on était là
on sert espace très que le routeur météo
voit que la cartographie s'étaient
arrêtées et même notre petite erreur
alors gerin perd finalement 1 ben ali
est actionné par elle-même
on a été chanceux pour ça
quel est une capitale est arrivé se
persuade équitation de chercher je me
suis dit que s'il cherchait pas un autre
bateau cani
[Musique]
c'est tellement appris durant la
traversée autant sur le point de vue la
renault scénic mais aussi dans la vie de
tous les jours quelque chose qui m'est
utile maintenant jeter encore plus prêt
à repartir des prochaines que si j'avais
poche à douille
[Musique]
alors ce serait dommage mais c'est
quelque chose qui nous a donné
l'occasion d'apprendre nous empêche pas
parfait
mais quand sanitaire